Free markets,
big tech and free speech often do not get along very
well because they have an interest to their, obviously to their investors.
And then you have things happening on Patrion,
like the actual financial backings,
like MasterCard kind of putting the pressure on to boot people.
And now there are so many different topics,
but I don't believe everyone has a right to a platform.
Let's shift a little bit here because let's talk about big tech because you've
got an interesting announcement coming. Uh,
but just relative to the whole big tech conversation.
And as someone that you now, you might be shadow banned.
And we don't know if they're going to get us and shadow banning as I keep
endlessly repeating is now quite literally in the Twitter terms of service.
If you are an American, it doesn't apply to the Europeans for some reason.
But if you're an American that is now in the terms of service on Twitter,
that they can throttle who sees your tweets on top of that,
I just saw as of the day, we're taping this today, um, that they're going to,
they're considering doing a tip thing on Twitter. Have you heard about this?
But think how dangerous that means. That's an interesting idea,
but now they're also saying they can throttle you,
but then that means they can also not just control who,
whose information gets out there, but who can actually make money too.
So it's a serious heat. Interesting. All that being said,
when it comes to big tech,
as someone that's in this as a creator and a YouTuber and a Twitter and a booed
person and all that stuff, um,
where are you on regulation and what we should do about this, this thing,
that's obviously pretty intimate.
So I had to think a lot about this. And I was always,
that was one area.
It just intersects with a lot of my interests is big tech free speech.
I'm like, Oh, this is going to be real interesting in the future.
And we'll see how well that holds up because free markets,
big tech and free speech often do not, you know,
get along very well because they have an interest to their,
obviously to their investors. And then you have things happening on Patrion,
like the actual financial backings,
like MasterCard kind of putting the pressure on to boot people.
And now there are so many different topics,
but I don't believe everyone has a right to a platform. So I just,
I don't think that everyone has a right to free speech in America. If in,
in the places where you are allowed to have free speech,
that doesn't mean that a private public square meaning the public square.
Now that doesn't mean that a private company owes you a
microphone. Yeah.
So what about the people that say, but, but Twitter and Facebook and YouTube.
Are the avenues we communicate.
And if they're, if you're not allowed on there,
it's like saying to somebody 30 years ago, you, you can't get a telephone.
You know, what's interesting to me is that it's generally people,
um, on the left who are saying, this are on the right, who are getting kind of,
but on the left it's like, get them all off Panama. It's not the public square,
but I think that wa it hurts, um,
really marginalized people, the most, the trickle down.
And so I don't know it to not consider it.
The public square is dangerous in some ways,
because then you are really, it's like,
but it's the, it's just so crazy. And it's just,
it goes to show how you're not gay because you
don't think the right way someone is isn't black.
If they don't think the right way, it's the ideology.
So if you have the right ideology,
you'll be allowed in the public square while that's not the public square,
but it is weird with Facebook and all these places. Because, um,
as far as I'm concerned, just being that they're private companies,
even if they were smart enough to create a public square,
they still get to do what they want to do. I mean,
I don't know what else to say about that. That's just, that sucks.
The best line I heard on this,
and this was in the middle of me trying to figure out how I wanted to fight this
battle was everyone always says,
but this time they have so much power that it's different.
So the idea would be that this time you libertarians, you kind of have to,
you have to put it aside and let the government do it because this is because
Google has so much information so much, or this is the time.
And then you're on Brookwood I've had on who you have.
You chatted with your own. You, you should definitely have him on, um,
from the Iran Institute, basically. I mean, it's the most simple thing,
but he said, it's so plainly as if it was nothing that it really just struck me.
He's like, well, if you wouldn't have principals,
when they're the hardest time to have those principles,
then you don't really have them. And so he's completely against, uh,
regulations. So that leads me to why over the last year, uh,
and I just announced it with barely a month ago,
I started locals.com to allow creators to own everything that they're doing own
all your content own, all of your user data set,
whatever rules you want in your locals. We started mine,
which we have about 10,000 people in there now@rubinreport.com.
And we got an iOS app and a Google play,
but I'm not pimping myself out here bridge it because this all leads.
To that. We are.
Pimping digits, boobs. No that you,
this is the first time it's being said publicly.
You are the first creator on locals.
People can go to [inaudible] dot com today.
P H E T S a Y E P H E
T a S Y. Yeah. Yeah. Is that what I said?
No, you said it say, that's fine. It's confusing dyslexia there.
We'll put it on the screen.
You are the first, you are the first creator beyond me.
That is on locals.com and we're super psyched to have you there.
And we had literally about 5,000 people that reached out that within that first
couple of weeks to create communities. And I was like Bridget, to the right one,
because you are just in the center of all of this. So I'm thrilled to tell that.
Honored to be here. I'm so excited.
I'm excited because while there's a couple of many reasons, one,
you put your money where your mouth is, you know, a lot. I appreciate that.
A lot of people, when I was, I was too small to really,
I was affected by people like, uh,
Jordan and you and Sam leaving Patrion,
because you took a lot of people who, who subscribed to me.
I had my own friends angry at me that were like, if you left.
Then it's okay. But, but people cancel their patriotic counts because of us.
So then a lot of you guys got it.
It's fine. Whatever. And again, I don't, I really don't like to be the,
you know, the victimy thing. So even I'm like, all right, shadow banned me.
All right, whatever. I'll figure out a way, because I always have,
you actually did figure out a way and made something.
And a lot of people are like, well, go make your own internet. They're like,
okay, fine. I will go make my own, you know, play. It's not a platform though,
isn't it?
Well, it's, it's a, it's a non platform platform.
It's a creator specific platform.
And one of the cool things that we're going to be launching over the next couple
of months, now that we're adding some creators. And you're just the first of a,
of a whole bunch of people that we're going to add is that we're going to be
able to connect our communities.
So you'll be able to connect your community with like-minded people.
So perhaps if, uh, Dave and Bridget, like each other,
we'll connect our communities, it'll,
it'll strengthen our feeds and our fans will be able to communicate with each
other. And if one day you're like that day, Rubin's real.
You'll just disconnect the connection and that's it. Um,
and the idea was,
let's give all of the power back to the creators that make sure that the day,
that the day that you say something on dumpster fire, that YouTube is.
Like, we're done with this girl. Well.
Guess what? You don't have any of, I mean,
think how many subscribers you have on a YouTube rebel.
Oh, I mean, I've only been on for like three months, so 11,000 about.
The day that they find you too much of a threat or whatever.
And hopefully by the end of.
This, by the end of this show, we're going to, we're going to send.
Some subscribers your way. But,
but the point is that you have no way of communicating with those 11,000 people.
They've.
Chosen to subscribe to your channel, but you can't.
Get your message out to them because the algorithm sits between you and getting
a message out to them. This gets adequate. I wish I had my phone on me.
You get actual push notifications on your phone. So I think we've built some.
No, it's amazing. I'm excited. I'm so excited. I'm excited. I,
I was telling David that I cried when I saw that. Yes, your David,
uh, that I cried when I saw it. Just the,
the S because it's just fantasy. So I started,
I made up the word fantasy years ago because,
and it means when reality becomes parody now in 2006, this didn't mean anything.
And now it's like, the culture has kind of caught up to the word. And then,
because social media was so new,
I used it as my social media name because they didn't really trust social media
and knew nothing about it. And I didn't. Um,
and I wanted to get the word out. Well,
I inadvertently became the brand before my company did,
because my company went bankrupt because I was 27 and didn't have a business
plan. I was going to make greeting cards again,
trying to just be a voice for people. I felt like didn't have a voice,
which was like divorced people and people who had kids out of wedlock. And,
and that's where I started. And then, um,
and then it took on a whole other life of its own, which is a crazy journey.
And probably the book I should write because it's been, and then I saw it,
you know, just fantasy back with the original logo. And I'm like, we, we,
I never gave up on this.
I have it on my phone. It's only it's the test version, but.
Always meant to be a content creation. That's all I want.
I wanted to be a production company. And two, I, like I said, I mean,
I w I have scripted podcasts. I want to make,
I have locals only content that I want to put on. And,
and I see locals now,
or the fetisi locals as my hub,
where I get to do that and just keep expanding and collecting people as long as
I'm allowed in the public forum. Yeah.
Yeah. But it's the home. I mean, what I'm trying to tell people is it's the,
it's your digital home. You do whatever you want and your digital home,
you can't, you know, our tos, our terms of service,
you can't break the laws of the United States across the board on locals.
But beyond that, one of the cool things is you set the rules in your locals.
I set the rules in my local. So if someone's just being purely evil in mine,
I just don't want your money and goodbye. You're out.
You may have a different policy related to what you,
what you're reading and mine. It's sorta, I wrote in, into kind of funny way.
It's like, it's not that I have three strikes. It's just like,
don't be a relentless Dick. And if you, if you just can't do that,
then I don't want, I don't, I literally don't want your money.
I mean, that's how I feel. It's I call it my, um, gated community.
Yeah. Congratulations. The new, well, the new institutions are being built.
What do you think though?
Because we're doing this as a subscription thing about that may be the day of
the absolutely free internet being the main driving force of everything is kind
of done. Cause that's sorta what I'm feeling like. Yes, I get it.
I'm not leaving YouTube or Twitter or any of those things for discovery,
but well, they just stole your soul. But besides.
I always say on Twitter,
I'm like Twitter takes your soul and all your information.
So one of the things I love about yours is that I take that stuff. I'm not,
I am not, I have no interest in selling information.
People give me to third parties, none.
I don't like it when other places do that to me, I have no interest in that.
If I shut down and die at all, dies with me.
That's also very clearly written for my partners. You know,
like I don't want them taking it and selling it. And I just,
I think that the, you know, I was saying,
as I was watching all of the past couple of
years,
the debates and the siloing of public and private
opinion is happening anyway. And I was saying,
everyone's going to end up going back to their domain names.
Everybody left their domain names to go into these, you know,
social media places.
And now everyone's going to start kind of reverting back to those places, their,
their homes, their home pages. Do you think that that's part of the problem,
you found a way to link them all and be social. So it's the future.
It's the future. It's amazing. Um, I'm psyched about, it's amazing.
I mean, I, when I saw, when you guys showed me the demo, I was like the,
I got in the car with cousin Maggie, and we're like,
this is the future because it's social media meets, you know, content creation.
It's like Patrion meets Twitter a little bit and it scrolls and it's
sexy. It's just, I'm so good.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.